تبدو صوره السلام في المنطقه قاتمه جدا مع
بدايه السنه الجديده
2024 جميع الشواهد
تشير ان السلام قد لا يتحقق قريبا
في ظل اولا
تطرف
اسرائيلي يصر اصرارا على مواصله العدوان
على غزه
وارتكاب جرائم حرب واباده جماعيه ضد 2
مليون فلسطيني في
غزه
[موسيقى]
و كل ذلك يتم
في ظل دعم امريكي وانحياز امريكي مطلق
لم نشهده في اي فتره من الفترات
السابقه
وايضا يبدو ان العائق الاخر
لتحقيق السلام الطرف
الفلسطيني المنقسم مع الاسف الشديد على
نفسه انقساما حادا يحول دون
تشكيل موقف فلسطيني واضح
وحاسم وهذا الانقسام
الفلسطيني
يزيده صعوبه
وتزداد
صعوبه في ظل غياب ايضا دعم عربي ودولي
واقليمي يعتد به فيما عدا ايران التي
تتاجر بقضيه فلسطين
لتحقيق اجندتها في المنطقه وتدفع باستمرار
ل
خيار المقاومه المسلحه التي تصطدم بعنف
اسرائيلي
مفرط
فبالتالي ومن الوهله
الاولى لا يبدو ان هناك شرطا لتحقيق
سلام قريب في
المنطقه والاحباط سيد الموقف والتشاؤم هو
السائد ان
المنطقه تتجه ربما نحو المزيد من العنف
ولا تتجه نحو تحقيق السلام
لكن هذا ليس وقت الاحباط والشعور
بالسوداوية
وقت العمل من اجل تحقيق
السلام واكثر من هذا وذاك في ظل او في
رحمي هذا الواقع السوداوي وهذه الكارثه
الانسانيه المروعه في غزه على اكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر
حاليا قد يلوح في
الافق امل بسيط بيص امل
و
فرصه لتحويل الازمه الى
مسار يحققه السلام المنشو في المنطقه الذي
تحول الى سراب كلما
اقتربنا منه شبرا ابتعد عنا ليس فقط مترا
وانما
امتار ولتحقيق السلام لابد من
توفير شرطين
اساسيين
وبدونهما لا يمكن السير في السلام والشرط
الاول او المسار الاول
قيام
حكومه اسرائيليه
جديده بديله لحكومه نتنياهو المتطرفه
اليمينيه المغالي في صهيون تها وعنصريتها
وعجرفة طبعا
وما يوحي بامل ان استطلاعات الراي تشير
الى ان هناك
استياء من حكومه نتنياهو واستطلاعات الراي
تشير الى رفض شعبي مطلق
ل شخص
نتنياهو
و الشواهد تقول انه في لحظه
انتهاء الحرب الحاليه على غزه ستكون ايام
نتنياهو وحكومته اليمينيه معدوده جدا ففي
حال
[موسيقى]
قيام حكومه اسرائيليه
جديده معتدله ربما مياله
للسلام تاخذ بعين الاعتبار ما حدث في 7
اكتوبر وكون ان اسرائيل لا تستطيع تحمل
عمليه اخرى على نسق سب اكتوبر
فهي فرصه الفرصه الاخرى والمسار الاخر
طبعا يتعلق بالطرب
الفلسطيني وفي هذا نحن ايضا بحاجه الى
حكومه فلسطينيه جديده حكومه وحده وطنيه
حكومه تمثل الضفه وغزه معا حكومه مختلفه
عن الحكومه الراهنه التي نعرف كم هي
مترهله وكم هي تعاني من الفساد وكم هي
تعاني من الانقسام ال
الشديد المطلوب ايضا حكومه فلسطينيه وحده
تشكل حكومه وحده
وطنيه
مؤقته تعالج اثار حرب غزه المدمره وتمهد
الطريق لانتخابات تشريعيه ورئاسيا قادمه
وتشكيل ربما بعد ذلك سلطه وطنيه
فلسطينيه تكون الطرف الاخر لتحقيق السلام
اذا
تحقق هذا الشرط وذاك الشرط حكومه
اسرائيليه جديده
وحكومه فلسطينيه جديده قد يقربون ذلك
لتحقيق السلام الذي طال انتظاره وقد تكون
هذه اكبر مفاجات سنه
2024 التي نتمنى ونتامل ونتطلع ان تكون
مختلفه عن سنه
2023 الحزينه التي كانت سنه
[موسيقى]
حرب